[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les autres
à
[Musique]
com
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais où
m
bon
[Musique]
ça vous donne des frissons
est ce que ça vous coupe le souffle en
2013 cette compétition le défi wind j'ai
réussi à la remporter
et bien ce souffle ce souffle c'est
celui de la compétition c'est quelque
chose qui pour moi est intégré depuis je
suis tout petit
parce que j'en ai besoin j'en ai besoin
dans le sens où cette compétition c'est
mon meilleur moyen pour réussir pour
réussir à mieux me connaître à mesurer à
moi même
cette compétition c'est une sensation sa
part du ventre ça fait comme des
milliers de papillons qui virevoltent à
l'intérieur et c'est une sensation
tonique comme ça qui part du coup et qui
se diffusent au long mais bras qui
glissent le long de mon dos et me
renforcer les jambes et au final il ya
quelque chose qui me dit aussi et allez
vas-y vas-y réaliste et rêve croisille
et ben quand je suis sur ma planche
c'est ce qui se passe je peux enfin
libéré tous ces papillons à l'extérieur
c'est cette excitation qui me donne
envie de me surpasser et ben c'est sur
l'eau que je m'exprime
c'est vraiment quand cette euphorie
elle fait place à l'action etc l'action
est fait place au plaisir
eh ben c'est ce que j'appelle avoir
l'esprit de compétition alors
dalé vu quand même sur sur les images
ont été sacrément nombreux plus de 1000
à poursuivre le même but
vous allez me dire mais il faut avoir un
mental d'acier pour réussir ou même pas
participé à cette compétition
ben oui c'est évident c'est évident mais
il ya que ce mental qui permet aux
sportifs d'être formaté comme une
machine à gagner parce que c'est un
mental qui se forge et ont rien n'est
laissé au hasard et aussi où rien ne
pourrait couronner cet acier
donc en fait ça en devient sportif
l'inoxydable imperméable parce que toute
façon rien mais tout est anticipée donc
il ya aucun doute à avoir
il est invulnérable parce que de toute
façon rien ne l'atteint et surtout ils
insensibles
ah oui parce que de toute façon un
moindre émotion est perçu comme une
faiblesse avec tout ça il doit gagner
il doit gagner et il doit éliminer toute
concurrence
alors là je vous entends vous allez me
dire mais oui mais c'est normal toute
façon c'est pas en claquant des doigts
qu'on devient champion bah ouais
sûrement peut-être que vous avez raison
mais moi je suis pas comme ça je suis
pas comme ça parce que pour moi la
compétition ça m'inspire c'est chaque
concurrent me pousse à me dépasser
ça me permit de d'être avec les éléments
en l'occurrence là c'est celle au et et
le vent et ben de faire voler tous ces
papillons qui sont en moi va encore plus
loin
plus fort encore plus intensément c'est
vraiment une sensation qui me permet que
de dire que la compétition que les
autres
maurice
et au final ben ça fait naître des
nouveaux papillon à l'intérieur de moi
et puis il ya autre chose aussi
je vais vous raconter une petite
histoire prenons une chenille petites
chenilles dont jardin c'est une plage et
au bout de cette plage bail à la mer et
bien sa curiosité à s'éveiller
quand il a commencé à avoir des exocet
savait assez des poissons volants et
bien s'élancer idée un peu folle
un peu folle d'aller nager et voler avec
ces poissons
pourquoi pas ben les débuts les débuts
ont été un peu laborieux un jeu là vous
elle a un peu bu la tasse mais alors
rien lâché non
après bon pas pour autant qu' il y avait
des cailloux et des nageurs qui est
poussé parce que toute façon une
chenille restera toujours une fini mais
pour ça eh ben c'est bien entraînés dans
le sens où on a passé des heures sur
l'eau et puis par toutes les conditions
par toutes les conditions j'entends par
là deux parce que croyez pas que la
plage c'est seulement soleil et
cocotiers on n'est pas en vacances
pas tout le temps mais ça peut être
aussi bain dans l'eau glaciale en plein
mois de janvier
c'est ça aussi eh ben
à partir de là une fois qu'elle était
prête une fois qu'elle s'était bien
m'entraîner rigoureusement est parti en
compétition lc l'a senti que c'était bon
moment le bon moment pour pouvoir ce que
ça faisait sauf que elle a quand même
découvert le vrai milieu le milieu qui
va au bout d'un moment et les baisses
des disqualifications des blessures la
casse de matériel alors là je vous passe
les détails
et puis des petites déceptions mais
surtout une grosse frustration
ben c'est faire des milliers de
kilomètres
à voir toutes les conditions réunies
pour faire une bonne compétition mais il
manque une chose il manque le vent et
ben ouais parce que la compétition c'est
ça aussi c'est soit on aime soit on
n'aime pas mais a jamais baissé les bras
cette petite chenille parce que pour
elle a été convaincue de faire les
choses de l aimer ce qu'elle faisait en
fait et puis donc elle a continué à
s'entraîner tout seul par elle même sans
club sans entraîneur pas de souci parce
que toute façon ce qui comptait c'était
vraiment d'aller naviguer sur toutes les
mers c'était de couvrir tous les vents
c'est de rencontrer de partager tout ça
ben tout ça c'était la vision de sept
petites chenilles
sauf qu'à était pas tout seul en
compétition
reprenons les exocet et bien il n'en
pensait pas moins de sa présence qu'est
ce que fait leur cette unis mais elle
restera pas dans l'eau toute façon c'est
pas dans ses gènes toute façon vous
l'avez vue est trop petit
et y arrivera jamais eh ben toutes ces
critiques
cette petite chenille et s'est pas
laissé faire parce qu'elle a enfin elle
a pris la décision de se forger ce
fameux mental d'acier
ce ce mental qui lui permettait de
devenir une guerrière et aussi de ne pas
cesser mettre la tête sous l'eau sauf
que n'avait pas prévu elle pas prévu
qu'elle deviendrait l'ombre d'elle même
parce qu'elle a compris qu'en fait pour
être en compétition pour exister il
fallait exceller et ça ça commence à la
rendre nerveux à la faire paniquer et
ben avait des gens qui tremblaient elle
avait mal au ventre mais c'est pas grave
dans ce sens où toute façon elle avait
ce mental d'acier donc ça lui donnait
l'air d'être un poisson volant
eh ben pour prouver qu'elle avait sa
place c'est voiler la face
alors vous allez me dire mais où est
passé son tour dias mme des débuts ben
c'est fini c'est la désillusion parce
que tous ses moyens employés pour
relever ce challenge pour vivre une
aventure pain elle a commencé à sentir
redevable redevables dans le sens où
toutes ces personnes qui croyaient en
elle eh ben elle était désolée de ne pas
être à la hauteur de leurs espérances
parce qu'au final c'était plus seulement
une histoire une histoire de potentiel
c'en est devenu une obligation de
résultat et de son rêve
elle en a fait un cauchemar
alors je fais pas de dessin hop on
revient dans le moment présent
eh bien c'est fini c'est moi voilà et
puis vous allez me demander aussi alors
comment comment comment j'ai fait en
étant si sensible pour m'adapter dans ce
milieu de compétition devenue si hostile
eh ben j'ai cru que en ramenant mon
titre de championne de france en 2014
j'aurais pu approuver quoi que ce soit
et bah c'était faux encore une fois je
laisse tromper parce que j'ai pensé
quand vous en plein des formes et bien
ce serait le bon chemin
évidemment ça n'a pas suffi pour battre
tout le monde hein à partir de là ben ça
c'est devenu compliqué parce que j'ai
tellement lutté lutté et luttent et
qu'au bout d'un moment je vois c'est moi
j'en ai marre j'en ai marre de devoir
ressemble aux autres parce que c'est pas
moins j'en ai marre de renfermer mes
émotions parce que si j'étais contente
j'étais prétentieux parce que si je
pleurais j'étais une chochotte
et puis j'ai commencé même à râler après
le vent alors vas-y vas-y khaled façon
qui en est qui on n'est pas c'est pas
toi qui va changer des choses hein mais
aussi ce qui m'a vraiment le plus blessé
c'était deux commencent à faire vivre un
enfer à mon entourage et ça un jour il
ya un mais prof d'ostéopathie qui m'ont
dit mais tu sais plus tu essayes de
rentrer dans un moule et plus tu
ressemblera une tarte
j'en ai pris une heure mais à ivato un
bail avait pas tort mais on fait quoi du
coup abandonné abandonné la compétition
chez moi non ça c'est pas possible
ah bah du coup je suis retourné dans mon
cocon voilà c'est qui me rassure ou ga
thiriez quand j'ai dl en feu
eh ben c'est auprès de ma famille c'est
auprès de ma famille ça m'a permis de me
reconcentrer de comprendre qu'ils
nourrissaient vraiment ma passion et de
me rendre compte de mon compte qu'en
fait c'était le vent ça a toujours été
le vent qui m'a procuré ce plaisir
intense en est là depuis tout à l'heure
en fait en train de parler de poissons
volants le chenil papillon ça vous
apparemment ça vous gêne pas mais j'ai
pris un peu de recul et au final on se
rend compte que le quai t2 entre un
poisson volant est un papillon
lequel des deux villes au mieux au gré
du vent mais c'est ça j'ai compris j'ai
compris que cette petite unis son but
c'était de devenir un papillon vous
savez c'est un de ceux qui volent dans
mon ventre alors c'est pour ça c'est
pour ça que tous les matins je continue
à regarder par la fenêtre comme salah
est inspecté la moindre feuille la
moindre brindille qui puisse bouger
analyser la vitesse élite s des nuages
et à comprendre d'où vient le vent non
je vais vous demander
je vais vous demander de participer et
de fermer les yeux à esi et confiance
fermez les yeux fermés les yeux et
imaginez
imaginez vous êtes au bord de la mer
vous sentez l'air sur votre peau vous
écouter le bruit du vent
prenez une bonne inspiration il soufflé
respirer merci
[Applaudissements]